uh let's uh do a quick review of uh
lecture three so last time we talked
about two key ideas about GPS right one
was uh how does the receiver determine
the position of the satellites and we
said that's done using the information
in the uh navigation messages
specifically the ephemeris part of the
navigation message has uh six parameters
in it which are called the orbital
parameters and uh with these parameters
three of them uh determine basically an
elliptical uh trajectory of the
satellite at a point in time and also
the position of the satellite within
that ellipse and the other three
determine the orientation of this
elliptical plane with respect to the
earth-centered Earth fixed coordinate
system okay so with those six parameters
the receiver can estimate very
accurately the position of the satellite
at a given point in time there's also
some correction parameters that that
tells the receiver how each of these six
parameters change over time so the
receiver can
extrapolate or interpolate between two
navigation messages and continuously
track the satellite's position very
accurately so that was the first uh
thing the second key idea we talked
about we kind of demystified this idea
of time of flight estimation using
ranging codes right so we basically
derived the least mean squares there at
least mean Square estimate of the time
of flight in a very general setup right
we formulated it as a optimization
problem some signal X of K is
transmitted which its waveform is known
to the receiver the receiver measures
yfk which is an attenuated and delayed
version of xfk and then we showed that
the optimal estimate of N Sub tau is
given by the index at which this
correlation function is maximized right
so you calculate this thing which is uh
very closely related to a convolution
and uh if you calculate this function
kind of you can also think of it as a
linear filter with kind of like the
kernel or the impulse response of the
filter being X of minus k or something
like that and then you can calculate
this function and if you plot it's uh
absolute value and the absolute value is
because
sometimes there could be sine flips so
that's why you take the absolute value
or you can also Square it and you find
the peak and the index at which the peak
happens is your
best estimate of the the time of flight
delay in the least Square sense okay
and then from this and this is true
about any c signal right whatever X you
send if if if this measurement model is
valid as long as this is this is a
measurement model then this is uh the
correlation is basically the optimal way
of determining your time of flight but
what is interesting about this is then
for when you're designing a system
you're free to choose uh what x of K is
and then based on this because at the
end of the day it's a correlation
function that matters you can choose an
X with good correlation properties and
by good properties we mean a nice sharp
Peak so you don't want this peak to be
too broad for instance because then
finding the the the peak the actual
maximum point of it could be a little uh
tricky and noisy situations and also you
want the side lobes to be very low okay
and then it turns out that there's many
many different uh uh codes as we call
them that have a good prop properties
the specific class that GPS uses are
called M sequences also called maximal
length sequences and we said that these
are good because they have specifically
three very uh interesting properties
they of course have good correlations as
we showed they have these triangle
functions with constant very low side
lobes they're extremely easy to generate
all you need is basically a shift
register with n Bits and some feedback
Taps and then you get a code with a
number of chips that is equal to 2 to
the N minus one so which is 10 bit shift
register you can generate a code that is
1023 bits or chips and also you can
generate multiple codes of the same
length with different shift register
feedback tabs and those codes each of
them has very good autocorrelation
and the other correlation functions are
in fact exact same between those but the
cross correlations are very low and this
low cost correlation is the key idea
behind code division multiple access
because the receiver can essentially
have different correlators with
different kernels
and each of them only
responds to the specific code that is
the kernel of that correlator and if you
pass a different code through it you
basically get not exactly zero but very
low output
okay any questions about this yes
question about um you said that you
should take absolute value in case there
are sign shifts like what what's a like
example of like a side shirt uh so an
example of a sign shift is uh for
instance
well here we said Alpha is just an
attenuation Factor right in reality
Alpha is can be a complex number because
there's also phase effects right and
once you make your Alpha a complex
number if you have a 90 degree phase
shift that's like a minus sign right so
so this Alpha if the phase effect gives
you like a 90 degree phase shift can
flip the sign of your X for instance
that's that's one example
um so so generally
um yeah that's that's why we take the
absolute value or squared
um okay uh any other questions
all right so let's continue the
discussion so
um
we said uh this was sort of like the the
ideal case but we said there's like
three um uh complications or
non-idealities that the receiver has to
deal with uh
first one was the Doppler shift right
and uh we'll get back to it and show you
like how Doppler shift is is compensated
for the other one was the fact that the
receiver clock is uh uh never perfectly
synchronized with the GPS clock right so
what happens is that there's some extra
shift in here just due to the receiver
clock offset that also needs to be
compensated for and that that's what we
called House of D and because of that
the receiver doesn't recover the
physical range it recovers what we call
the pseudo range right and the third one
which we didn't quite finish we just set
up the problem is this idea of range
ambiguity and the idea of region
ambiguity is
um
so the signals that are being
transmitted are periodic so the
correlations also are periodic right we
usually just calculated over one period
of the signal right so in here for
instance if this was in this picture if
this was the ca code your correlation
you can start from index zero and only
go to
um
10 22 right only one one period of of
your signal but uh
uh in reality
um the n hat that you find from here the
physical and hat can be that plus any
multiple of the code length right uh so
it could be n hat one plus K plus 2K
plus 3K and so on and so forth and
that's why we have this ambiguity in our
ranging and we need to exactly find what
is the correct so the actual physical
time of flight is n hat one plus some
M times K and remember K is the number
of samples in the code and we need to
find what is m is m equal to one is it 2
m is an integer right so you need to
disambiguate that that integer M which
corresponds to the physical range so how
can we do this
there is a simple solution which is
basically if we have some idea roughly
of what the actual time-of-flight delay
is or what the actual pseudo range we
expect from the satellite is okay
roughly doesn't need to be exact but if
you know that so that can help us
disambiguate between these uh Solutions
basically that we get from the
correlation so for instance one thing we
know is that the GPS satellites they
they are orbiting the Earth at an
elevation that is 2 200 kilometers okay
so if the receiver was exactly below one
of these satellites then the the the the
the range would be 2 200 kilometers but
in reality these satellites cover a
large portion of the earth so your range
or pseudo range can be hundreds or
possibly thousands of kilometers
away from this number okay that's still
okay that's a ballpark now where to work
with so let's see if if that is useful
for this ambiguation so uh
in order to see what we can do we need
to know basically what is from one Peak
to the next what is the Delta range
right and is that large or small
compared to this number if it's very
large then only one of the Peaks would
be very close to this number so let's
calculate that so the range variation
Delta R is c times the Delta Tau and the
Delta Tau we are talking about is
between two basically adjacent peaks in
this extended correlation function so
what is the Delta Tau it's basically the
number of samples between two two of
those Peaks times your sampling time
number of samples it's basically M times
n so remember this is this is our k
right total number of samples in a in a
discretized code and this would be equal
to n times the the chip time interval or
also you can write it as c times the
total duration of a code
right so that's the Delta range that you
get between two consecutive Peaks so
what is that actually equal to let's
look at uh a few uh
a few numbers here so for instance if
you're working with the py code this was
the military code uh let's see what the
range ambiguity for that is a chip
duration for that is 97.8 nanoseconds
and it has very large number of chips
remember this was 6 times 10 to the 12
chips so you calculate your Delta R it
comes out as 1.8 times 10 to the 11
kilometers right with this Delta R it's
very very easy to disambiguate right
because if your Peaks are in the core in
the extended correlation are this far
apart of course there's only one of them
that is even remotely close to this
number so with py not a problem right
you can easily disamigate your range how
about the civilian code let's look at
the ca code so the ca code remember was
much much shorter right so it has a chip
duration of 977.5 nanoseconds total
number of chips is 1023 plug the numbers
into our Delta R equation and it comes
out to almost 300 kilometers with this
we have a problem right because if if
these peaks in the extended correlation
I'm going to go back if these Peaks are
only in range 300 kilometers apart
we cannot decide which one we can be
multiple of them could be the actual uh
physical range right
it's not enough separation to let us
disambiguity yes
it's the one that has like the the
lowest relation so the the for like the
lowest distance
well because that
the question is why not why not pick the
peak which is do you mean closest to the
20 000 number is that
okay well because
um physically that might not be right so
if I draw a picture here for you let's
say this is this is the Earth and we
have a satellite here
okay remember these satellites cover
a very large surface area right a very
wide beams so if your receiver is
directly under this guy if you're here
then you're 20 000 k
okay but if you're here you could be 40
000 kilometers or something I mean we
can't exactly calculate I I don't know
off the top of my head like what's the
the Delta is but this can be
yeah uh thousands of kilometers away
from from 20. and and if our Delta
ranges are only 300 kilometers it it is
not enough okay so the simple idea
doesn't work for the for the civilian
code uh what do we do
it turns out that this strange
disambiguation there's multiple way ways
around it and different GPS
manufacturers they kind of have their
own secret sauce of like how they do
this and they don't of course tell us
what they do but there's ideas out there
and and which which can work so if you
were to for instance Implement your own
uh you can pick some of these and
there's more than the three ideas listed
here but these are the easier ones so
one is
um well
the range from or the pseudo range from
each satellite is ambiguous right but we
always have multiple satellites to work
with so you can use your multiple
measurements and remember these should
Define spheres that intersect at almost
one point so based on that geometric
constraint that can help you
disambiguate and pick the pseudo ranges
that are geometrically consistent okay
so that's one idea the other one is even
with just one satellite if you wait for
the satellite to move a little bit in
orbit by a non-negligible amount then
that movement you know the exact
trajectory of the satellite and again
that's another geometric constraint that
can help you disambiguate what's the
true range you can pick the pseudo range
that is consistent with your trajectory
of the satellite that you're estimating
so that's the second idea the third one
doesn't have any um basically geomet
geometry grounding it's it's more a
about the structure of the of of the
bits in the lnap messages so there's
this uh thing called the bit
synchronization and that has to do with
how the codes and the navigation message
frames are are arranged inside the GPS
data packets and that bit
synchronization can help you
disambiguate uh it gets a bit technical
but I just wanted to put the idea out
there in case you want to read more
about it so those are some ideas and uh
you could use these or other ideas to to
disambiguate but
an important point is this range
ambiguity
uh it's only a problem to solve when you
cold start your receiver and my cold
start we mean you just turn it on you
have no idea where you are it's the very
first position fixed that you want to
make and then you have this ambiguity
problem as soon as your first position
fix comes in for the for the next one
you can always use your previous
estimate to disambiguate right because
remember for instance the ca code is
updating every millisecond right so in
principle every millisecond you can
update your position and in a
millisecond you're not going to move by
much or your pseudo range is not going
to change by much so you can always look
at the previous one and then go back to
the simple idea and say okay my previous
pseudo range was 25 000 kilometers my
next one I just choose the peak that is
close to that okay so this is again it's
it's only a challenge after a cold start
you do your first thing and then and
then you get going with the with the
simple method of range this ambiguation
okay so with this I think uh we have
cleared uh the the two uh important
things that the receiver needs to do we
now know how the locations in orbit are
calculated for the satellites and we
also know how time of flight is
calculated using the ranging codes the
one thing we have not clarified yet is
um basically or two things one is how is
a Doppler shift estimated and how is the
timing offset compensated for okay so
we'll talk about those and of course we
have not yet gotten to a point where we
actually use these pseudo range
measurements to localize ourselves
um that's also a topic of the discussion
for today any questions
before we
continue okay so
um
so we talked a lot about the physics we
developed a signal model we also
developed a mathematical model of how
ranging using these codes work now we
are at a level where we can start
looking at the GPS receiver from a
system level right so now we're going to
build a system model for the GPS
receiver let's look at the transmitter
very briefly we are not going to spend
too much time on it so this is the
satellite model
in reality it's a lot more complex than
this but what we care about is that
there's a local oscillator that
generates a carrier frequency and then
there are two signals modulated on it
right so there is the x of T which is
our ranging code let's say the ca code
and then there is a det which is the
navigation message and uh the the the
data rates are very different one is
very fast megabits per second the other
one is very slow bits per second and
then basically the signal is transmitted
to us via an antenna right and this is
the signal model
and here just to make the math a little
more tractable you're ignoring the
quadrature so we assume for now we are
only transmitting an in-phase component
right so that's why there's just a
cosine 2 pi fct we are ignoring the sign
right just just to make the math uh a
little easier to track but everything we
say is General even if you have both
quadratures in there everything will
work out okay so that's the transmitter
part you're going to spend a lot more
time on the receiver system architecture
so this is what it's it looks like so
this is kind of like a system block
diagram of what a GPS receiver is it of
course has an antenna it's going to
receive a signal called that Sr of t
and then from a high level functional
point of view these are these are the
the main blocks in the in the receiver
there's an RF front end and then the
signal from there goes to an analog to
digital conversion block or an ADC then
there is a demodulation block which
takes input from a numeric numerically
controlled oscillator or an NCO and then
the output from that goes to the
correlator which has an input from a
local code replica generator and at the
output of the correlation we need to
basically find and track uh the the peak
index which basically is a measure of
the pseudo range right the demodulation
block specifically what it does is that
it finds and tracks and cancels the
Doppler shift for us as we'll see and
the correlation block as we know
basically finds and tracks Tau plus Tau
D so the or or the the range okay so
this is high level now what we're going
to do is we are going to kind of double
click on each box if you will and go a
level deeper and track the signal from
the input to the antenna all the way to
the output of the correlator and uh
basically do the full derivation of what
happens to our signal as it's it's
processed through the system okay so
first let's look at the RF run-in
uh so this here basically everything you
see here is basically inside the RF
front end right so we're zooming in and
seeing what's what's happening and
inside what we call the other front end
okay so there's a signal coming in
that's Sr
um uh that's the power in it root uh to
PR and then there's the navigation and
the code uh signal that are delayed by
the time of flight right so D of T minus
Tau X of T minus Tau and then you have
your carrier that is shifted by the
Doppler shift so you get 2 pi of FC
which is the nominal carrier frequency
plus the Doppler shift right and there
is some phase shift due to basically
again on the the propagation delays and
um just to make our model more complete
we're adding a noise term here so this
nft is an oyster okay
um and then it can be any noise model
usually uh White gaussian noises is
what's assumed for these systems but it
can be anything so what happens here is
basically first you have a low noise
amplifier LNA and we assume it has some
gain g and then the signal goes through
a RF bandpass filter centered at the
nominal carrier frequency F Sub C why do
we have the filter because we only want
to work with where the information is
everything that is far away from the
carrier frequency is just noise and
interference that we want to filter out
as as early as possible then we have our
first demodulation step so what happens
here is we have a local oscillator that
is generating this sine wave at the
nominal carrier frequency offset it but
what is called the intermediate
frequency so it's it's generating a
cosine 2 pi FC minus FIS T right
why that why why not just
demodulate by FC why why are we going to
this intermediate frequency it's an
architecture decision there's nothing
wrong with going uh basically
demodulating right down to FC but this
idea which is called the heterodyne
architecture it's used a lot in
Communications and the reason is usually
if you look at the the noises Spectrum
the closer you get to DC things get more
noisy right there's the one over F noise
there's other effects that make
basically the DC portion of the spectrum
pretty noisy so you want to delay
bringing your signal down to that part
of the spectrum to the digital domain
because then you don't mix in all these
analog low frequency noises to your
signal so you first bring it just
so I were to draw a picture of the
spectrum so if this is f what you
receive first is centered at FC which is
your carrier frequency well technically
FC plus adoptler shift but but Doppler
shift is a small relative to your
carrier frequency this is kilohertz
carrier is
gigahertz right but anyway so you have
some signal around this
and the first step brings this down
and let's say this is zero
brings us down to some intermediate
frequency
still we have the FD offset right so you
come here
and then later in DSP you bring it
further down as we'll see to base span
and then you do your correlation and
again the reason you come here first and
not directly to around DC is that
there's a lot of noise usually around
here so there's noise
and you don't want to directly bring
your signal to the noisiest part of the
spectrum it's just one architecture
Choice there are systems that uh do
homodyne which brings brings it directly
to to the DC
Okay so
so signal so what happens is that uh
well first s is multiplied by the gain
of the lone noise amplifier so that's
we're just modeling it as a gain block
so we are not going
um
to the detail of like what the actual
frequency response of this is just
assume signal is in band and it's just
this G multiplier and then you filter it
and then the important things happens at
this mixer where you basically multiply
uh this this local oscillator output
with your signal so you get cosine of FC
minus fif times cosine of FC plus FD and
you get two cross terms right one is at
the sum frequency one is at the
difference frequency the sum of the the
difference of the two frequencies the F
carrier cancels out and you're left with
this frequency which is your Doppler
shift plus the intermediate frequency
and the second term is that the sum
which goes to twice the carrier
frequency right so you go to 2fc plus F
sub D minus f i right then what you do
is you put a band pass filter centered
at the intermediate frequency and what
the band pass filter does is it filters
out this part this term which is 2fc
right because again in this picture the
one that's a 2fc this goes way out right
that copy would be here Center that to
SC
and then when you bandpass filter around
here
this guy
goes up
so that's that's what the fam pass
filter does for you and what comes out
we call it the intermediate frequency or
Sif signal yes
uh great question so the question is why
is there a phase shift this Theta hat
Theta tilde in the local oscillator
because it's not we don't it's not face
face locked to the received signal so
that's just a non-ideality in this
system so the receive signal is coming
with some some unknown phase Theta
um and I'm generating some sine wave so
this also has its own phase because I
don't know the phase of the carrier to
lock to it my local oscillator is free
running so its output is going to have
some some Theta TLD
relative to the hospital you can yes
maybe that's a better better choice but
I I wanted to be kind of more explicit
and like what's phase locked and what's
not so I'm I'm kind of like
intentionally adding the two thirds but
you're absolutely right I mean
mathematically you can just say Theta is
relative to my Lo and make this zero
perfectly fine
Okay so
um
let's continue okay so this is this is
again this Sif is what comes out of your
low pass filter just this uh term at the
the double uh the two FC uh is filtered
out and you're you're left with what is
DFT sub uh T minus Tau X of T minus Tau
times cosine of the doubler plus the
intermediate frequency plus the Delta
Theta so in your notation uh this is the
the Delta Theta so I'm just calling
Theta minus Theta tilde Delta Theta and
that's exactly what your suggestion and
then your noises are still there it's it
the noise is also going through this
entire chain right so it gets tilted it
gets Amplified and tilted and mixed down
and again filtered so now we are calling
it the intermediate frequency noise okay
so uh next is uh you have the ABC and
the double demodulation right ADC is
easy so your intermediate frequency
signal is coming in we're just sampling
it with some sampling rate FS or
sampling interval T sub s so you get s i
f of n which is uh F of n times TX
and here what we have is uh basically we
want to separate out the in phase and
quadrature components of our signal
right and we also want to compensate or
cancel out the Doppler shift right so we
have what we call a numerically
controlled oscillator so it is an
oscillator whose output frequency and
and phase can be controlled by a
numerical input right so it takes in a
kind of like a nominal oscillator or a
fixed oscillator input and then a second
input that is kind of like a knob to
tune the output frequency and phase of
of this thing right and let's say for
now the receiver has some estimate
somehow will will tell you where this is
coming from the F hat but if you have
some estimate of what the Doppler shift
is you can tune your numerically
controlled oscillator to Output a a sine
and a cosine term that is exactly at fif
plus F doubler or F hat Doppler okay so
F hat Doppler is the receiver's estimate
of the Doppler shift okay and fif the
intermediate frequency is known so
because the receiver knows uh uh where
where it brought the or what
intermediate frequency is using
and then you have to do another mixing
basically of your discretized if signal
and one is mixing with a cosine term the
other one is mixing with a sine term and
uh this is just uh some algebra here
again you uh multiply the two terms you
get or multiply them and you get two
times one at the sum frequency one at
the difference frequency and if you put
a low pass filter here
it only gives you the difference
frequency output the sum gets filtered
out exactly as it happened with the with
the first mixer
and you're left with this so again we
have this guitar so now we have D of NTS
minus Tau times x of NTS minus Tau times
the cosine of this is again we're
keeping just the difference frequency
which is the the actual Doppler shift
minus our estimate of the Doppler shift
right so you get FD minus F at D plus
some phase term right and noise is also
just carrying through
here again so so we now have two outputs
right there's an in phase and there is a
quadrature so that's the s i and the SQ
is exact same except you have a sine
instead of a cosine right now here's
something interesting
if somehow your estimate of the Doppler
shift is perfect both the frequency and
the phase okay then what happens if your
estimate is perfect is this term is zero
right the the Delta Theta term is also
zero so you get cosine of zero for your
end phase which is one right what do we
get for the quadrature same thing so the
the argument of the sine term becomes
zero you get sine of zero which is zero
so your quadrature term becomes just
noise right
which exactly makes sense so if you are
correctly estimating and tracking your
Doppler shift and that phase term here
your si signal just becomes some
constant times the lnap message times
the coding range plus noise
and your quadrature signal becomes just
noise which makes complete sense because
we started with the assumption that we
are not transmitting anything in the
quadrature right so of course our
quadrature output for now is just noise
if you had a q component you you would
get some real output in here okay again
uh this is I'm I'm going really detailed
in here because I think it's important
to be comfortable with this type of
system level analysis that like you have
a system design you know the blocks you
kind of you know break it down and track
your signal down the chain and you can
exactly derive what is happening to the
signal as it's going through each of
these blocks okay so now we are on to
something right because if you look at
here
uh we have gotten rid of all the carrier
modulation and the Doppler shift right
and we have kind of down to where what
we care for we want to we want to get to
a point where we just have the delayed X
and then we can correlate it with our
local Replicon and find the peak and
we're very very close to that in fact we
are exactly there why because here what
we don't like is well this is just a
constant G times root P that's fine
multiplicative constant don't don't care
noise is always there you're never gonna
get completely rid of noise so fine it's
going to be some noise added to the
output of the correlator it's the lnav
message here that's that's that's that's
that's annoying right
um but is it really annoying
um and the answer is no uh why is the
answer no because remember this D
varies very very slowly compared to the
coding range a coding signal uh I'm
sorry ranging code and because this
varies very very slowly you can assume
this D is also constant on the time
scales that you care for correlation
like milliseconds you can assume D is
just either a plus one or a minus one
which also
um
is related to the question raised
earlier that why do we take the absolute
value of out of the correlator this is
another case where there could be a sign
shift if our D is equal to a minus one
versus a plus one that could make a sign
shift at the output of the correlator
but we take the absolute value so that
that's not important okay so then we are
essentially done so all we need to do is
now run a correlation on on this
demodulated and Doppler compensated
signal and uh find the peak the way the
receiver operates is instead of uh um
actually generating one fixed replica
code and calculating the correlation for
all possible values with n and then
doing a peak search instead it does it
the other way around it generates a
shifted uh replica code by what it
thinks the time of flight is so it's it
it generates an X of NTS plus doubly
this is the time delay a plus Tau hat
which is the receiver's estimate of the
time of flight and then it looks at the
correlation just at the zero Index right
and if this Tau hat is is right is
correct then the peak would happen at
zero does this make sense so instead of
basically
um
calculating
r x hat
y of n as a function of n
and then
searching through this function and
finding where our n hat tau is this is
one way of doing it the receiver
actually
just monitors the output of the
correlator at zero and instead finds
R hat of n minus
n Tau and varies the N Tau as a knob to
bring this as it's a linear operation
right so if you shift the input that the
peak is going to shift you can always
just monitor the value of the
correlation at zero and if you're
this shift value is equal to n hat you
bring this peak
to zero
and if you maximize this value that
means you found the correct n hat so
that's how the the receiver actually
operates it generates the shifted
version of uh shifted replica of the of
the code and kind of varies the shift
varies this Tau hat
until the output of the correlator at
zero is maximized and and then it's like
ah I found the towel hat because they
perfectly aligned what I received with
the shifted replica of the code and and
that's my my top hat okay and uh
mathematically again this is what it is
I mean this is don't get scared off by
this it's I I've put everything in there
I'm just so you get comfortable with
like this kind this level of of detail
when you're analyzing your your system
but we can break it down again uh this
is just all the all the multiplicative
constants right G was the gain of the
low noise amplifier root PR is the
received basically signal power D is our
navigation message I'm taking it out of
the submission because we said we can
assume it's a constant right so this T
is either plus one or a minus one
depending on what the value of the lnav
message was at the time this one over NC
is is just the constant for the cyclic
correlation because we Norm it's a
normalization constant but a number of
samples and then the cement Nation
inside is this is what you've received X
of NTS minus Tau right the discretized
ranging code this one is what the
receiver generates right so it's the
copy of the code or the local replica of
the code which is anti-subastic again
it's sampled at the same sampling rate
there's a plus Tau D here that's the
timing offset of of the receiver and
then this Tau hat again is what we are
trying to find and match it to Tau right
so the receiver
various towel hot
and looks at this number which is the
value of the correlation at zero and
when this number SI is maximized that
means uh your Tau hat is equal to Tau
this you have perfectly aligned things
yes
oh yeah you're exactly right and uh it's
it's actually Tao hotline study I'm I
was assuming how D is zero but you're
absolutely right
again what is this cosine we'll get to
that but let me finish this so what is
this cosine term here that's the
basically the residual modulation if
your estimate of the Doppler shift is
not perfect right so this Delta F here
is the actual Doppler shift minus your
estimate of the Doppler shift if you are
estimating Doppler shift perfectly this
becomes zero the Delta Theta becomes
zero and this whole cosine term becomes
one it doesn't matter right but it's
very important because this means if you
are not estimating your Doppler shift
correctly you get this extra cosine term
inside the summation and that can
completely kill
the output of your correlator as as
we'll see so that's why it's essential
to have Doppler compensation if you
don't it can significantly reduce that
Peak value or even entirely kill it um
and uh
so so so just to summarize again we are
assuming D of T is equal to either plus
or minus one so we assume it constant uh
in the time scales of the correlation
and to maximize this
what we call S Sub I output two things
need to happen for that thing to get
maximized one is as I said you have to
track and compensate for Doppler
correctly so that Delta F term should be
zero which means your estimate of the
Doppler shift should be equal to the
actual Doppler shift and also the your
estimate of the phase should be the
actual phase and and that makes that
cosine term zero that's number one
number two which is exactly what saksham
said is your Tau hat should be equal to
Tau plus Tau D and the tauhat again is
like as you generate this local replica
of the code you're shifting it around by
Tau hat and seeing at what value of it
I'm maximizing my correlator output and
the value at which it maximizes is
exactly Tau plus Tau D if tally was Zero
if you had no timing offset that means
you had found the actual physical time
of flight but because it's always
non-zero you find the time of flight
plus your timing delay
okay
and uh and and this is graphically what
what it happens again assume we're we're
plotting things as a function of of the
tauhat which is how much the receiver
shifts around the uh the replica code
that it's generating and this is the
output of the correlator plotted as a
function of tauhat so it's a small small
small small and suddenly it Peaks and it
Peaks where your Tau hat is equal to Tau
plus Tau D and once you find that Peak
you just hold it there you're like I
found the peak
and and that's my time of flight right
or time of flight plus my timing offset
so this is for the in Phase the
quadrature output is just noise so you
just feed noise to the correlator you
get noise out there's no peak and that
makes sense because we didn't send
anything over the quadrature in this
example if you had another code over
quadrature that correlator would also
have its own Peak you know related to
the other ranging code
does everything
[Music]
fully makes sense so feel free to ask
questions I mean it's it's important to
clarify things
still no questions all right
Okay so
so this was kind of like at a system
level again uh let's uh
look at this slide real quick so we
fully basically traced signal from the
input of Our receiver system through the
entire signal chain from the the
amplification uh the the heterodyne down
conversion analog to digital conversion
and then the second step demodulation
with the with the with the Doppler
tracking and then finally the
correlation and then tracking basic or
finding this
Peak at the correlator output which
happens when two things are correct one
is our estimate of Doppler should be
correct and our estimate of basically
the time of flight plus our timing
offset should be uh correct and and and
that's when we get a large Peak at the
output of the correlator okay
now I still haven't told you
how do we make these two conditions
satisfied right so you still need to
again you cold start your
receiver how do you estimate Doppler and
how do you make F hat equal to F hat D
equal to FD and how do you found set
your your Tau hat equal to Target it's
actually
um
pretty straightforward so that's this
idea of acquisition and tracking so
after a cold start there's two phases of
operation for a GPS receiver first is
called the first one is called
acquisition and in the acquisition phase
basically the receiver needs to find its
first estimate of what the Doppler shift
is and what the pseudo ranges or the
time equivalent of it which is Tau plus
Tau d
for multiple satellites right for at
least four satellites you need to find
both the Doppler shift and and the
pseudo range or the time equivalent of
it and after that that's called the
acquisition phase right which is
typically slow it can take 10 seconds
for instance for an older GPS receiver
and after you find that first
estimate for every satellite of FD and
topless Tau D then you can go to a
tracking phase because from there on
it's the first estimate is a little
trickier to find but afterwards uh
because you're operating on very small
time scales uh you can just track these
things are going to vary slowly like you
always have a previous estimate of your
Doppler shift and for your next estimate
you use your previous estimate as a
starting point and you just track the
variations of it around the your
previous estimate same for uh pseudo
range you always have your previous one
and the next one you can just you know
track how how much it changed so
tracking is fast because you don't you
know you have a very good estimate
already of of where these values should
be okay so
um let's start with the acquisition so
essentially what you have to do you have
a 2d search space right one dimension is
Doppler shift the other day mentioned is
tauhat or or that the time equivalent of
the pseudo range right and uh what's
good is that both of these are bounded
right we said for instance that Doppler
shift for
um typical applications of you know
vehicles and robots on the surface of
the Earth is bound to plus and minus 10
kilohertz all right and then for your
Tau hat because these correlations are
periodic you just need to search over
one period of the correlation which for
instance for a CA code you have 10 023
chips to search through and that's
exactly what
um the um that the receiver does so
again for a course acquisition code you
have F hat between minus and 10 and 10
kilohertz you have Tau hat between zero
and one millisecond so one millisecond
again is the duration of one full
ranging code and you perform a 2d search
here's the the graphically how it's done
so you have two axis is you have your
Doppler shift going from -10 to 10 and
you have your Tau hat I'm in I'm showing
it in units of chips but you can also
convert that to time so it goes from 0
to 10 23 or in time it goes from zero to
one millisecond right and then you do a
grid search basically that's exactly
what the receiver does so you start from
one Whatever combination like Doppler
shift minus 10 kilohertz and Tau hat
zero and you monitor the output of your
correlator that's just one number right
that s i that was coming out of your
correlator and you do your grid search
you just you know search the Grid in
some pattern and when you hit the right
combination of Doppler shift and how hot
you get a very large output out of your
correlator and you typically have some
acquisition threshold and you monitor
the output of your correlator and when
it goes above that you're like all right
I I I acquired my
satellite which means I have an estimate
a very good estimate of both the Doppler
shift and and and the sudo range right
you can look at slices here just so you
get an idea of how sensitive you are to
um you know
residual errors in in Tau or in Doppler
usually the way these codes behave
mathematically is that in
in Tau you're extremely sensitive so
here's a slice for at the I'm showing
you a slice of this 2D function for the
correct Doppler so here already we have
found the correct FD and we're just
varying Tau here right and you only see
a very sharp Peak where your tauhat is
equal to Tau plus Tau D and if you're
one bin off essentially or one chip off
in code you get almost nothing and
that's again because that was the
mathematical property of these M
sequences the correlation has a very
sharp Peak and then it quickly drops to
almost zero right so that's that
it's a little more forgiving so if you
look at the the the the slice at the
right towel hat so you have found your
pseudo range correctly and you just have
some residual air in Doppler that's
that's a behavior it's almost like a
sync function right so at the correct
Doppler when F hat is equal to the
actual Doppler of course that's its
maximum and then it drops it's still a
pretty short draw right so remember that
like end to end this is just 20
kilohertz right but you can be off by
a few hundreds of Hertz and still have a
decent you know output out of your
correlator but if you're off by more
than I know like 250 kilohertz or so uh
250 Hertz or so you almost entirely kill
um the correlation output and that's
that's actually a good thing this is not
a bad thing because the the fact that
these both these Peaks are reasonably
sharp it means that you can very
accurately find both the Doppler shift
and the and the Tau hat with the with
the 2D search so this is the acquisition
phase and this is why it's a slow
because you need to do a full 2D search
over a grid and I'll get to your
question in a second but but real quick
just so you get an idea of how big of a
search you need to do so for a CA code
uh you want to search all of your uh
range basically bins and uh so let's say
the full code is uh one millisecond and
one chip is 0.98 microseconds so again
you almost have or you exactly have 10
1023 range bins to search or Tau happens
to search and then for Doppler a typical
number for the size of these Doppler
cells for the search is 250 Hertz and
then you have a 20 kilohertz
basically Doppler bandwidth to search so
that's 80 times roughly a thousand so
about 80 000 combinations of tauhat and
FD that you need to search and that's
why on all the receivers it takes few
seconds I mean really on Modern things
this can be done in super quickly I mean
we're talking probably tens of
milliseconds to get the first fix it's
it's not really that bad because each of
these remember to each search at the end
of the day what you want you want to get
one number out which is just an inner
product with the shifted replica of the
code and what you received and you just
want the correlation value at zero so
that's just one inner product that you
do and that gives the value of this
function question
um
are the Doppler effects going to change
yeah that's why you need to do it
relatively fast yes uh and again
so so so for instance if if you are on
uh just to repeat the question was as
you're doing the search isn't the
Doppler going to change right
um there's two things first you you do
it relatively fast so we're talking like
seconds at most for really old receivers
modern ones probably milliseconds but
also even if it's changing so let's say
you're on some vehicle that is
accelerating extremely fast so the
Doppler is like ever changing something
like that
um you can still you know get lucky like
you're searching and this thing is is
moving you can still like intersect it I
mean it might jump over you right but
but if you if you do a few passes you're
going to catch it even if it's shifting
around if you do it fast
um okay other questions
no all right so okay so uh so that's so
so that's the the acquisition step and
uh
what you want to do you want to acquire
multiple satellites right so for that
the receiver has so that basically
signal chain that I showed you imagine
that the receiver has multiple of those
in parallel right so your signal is
coming in and when it comes to Doppler
compensation and the correlation the
receiver can have multiple channels
and for each each of them is basically
uh acquiring and tracking a specific
satellite right and again this is where
this idea of code division multiply
access really helps because each of
these correlators if it's correlating
with a local replica of a specific code
so let's say this one is doing with
course acquisition number one this is
CA number two and so on and these are
known codes we know exactly what the
code every satellite is transmitting is
then if you feed the ca2 into this
you you're not going to affect the
output of the correlator because the
cross correlation of these codes is very
low and that's how
um kind of like the magic part of the
magic of these codes is that this this
uh almost orthogonality through the
correlation naturally filters out
interferences from other channels right
um so so again in this space of Doppler
and pseudo range or Tau hats I'm I'm
using time and range interchangeably as
as you've noticed so in my mind like
tauhat and pseudo range which is just
Taha times the speed of light is this
the same same thing it's like time and
time and space are kind of
interchangeable but you have this thing
which is tauhat between zero and one
millisecond and F hat from -10 and 10
and then you acquire a bunch of
satellites and each of them is basically
a point in this 2D search map right so
you acquire your satellites you acquire
at least four and then from there on the
job of the receiver is a little easier
so so you go into tracking and as I said
the tracking is basically on this
picture each of these points over time
it's going to move around because both
the Doppler is going to change and the
range or pseudo range is going to change
but it doesn't randomize right if you do
this fast from now to a few milliseconds
from now things don't change that fast
so you only need to like limit when we
started at the cold start your search
space was this entire square right yep
images
but there's many unique region codes as
there are satellites yes exactly yes uh
the question was are there as many
unique ranging codes as satellites and
yes this
is three channels
and hardware for every GPS receiver yet
uh yeah you can but uh these are the
number of channels I mean if if it's
fully implemented in Hardware yes but
these days these are like software
defined right so the the local replica
there's like this is all in digital
right
um so assume like a microcontroller or
an fpga and then it can
basically in in runtime change what code
it's it's correlating against
um old ones it was all in Hardware
actually and yes they had almost like at
the time whatever the numbers allies was
but these days it's it's software
defined so they have like I don't know
eight or ten channels at a time and then
they kind of flip through the codes and
find like uh which ones give a response
basically
okay so uh so so then the idea of
tracking like when you're cold start you
for acquisition phase uh you need to
search the big search space which is
like 80 000 combinations but when you go
to tracking you basically just just
around this you limit your search uh by
a few bins and see how these things uh
move over time and that's basically the
idea of tracking so you have like a
tracking region around the uh the the
point corresponding to every satellite
uh and then you kind of track what it's
done
um the algorithms were tracking they can
be super super simple so for instance
for to track uh towel hat the simplest
one you can do if we go back to this
picture which was I believe
here
yeah if you go to this picture to track
how hot for instance how it's changing
over time what you can do is that at the
output of your correlator instead of
just looking at uh at this peak if you
also look at the sample like the one
before and the one after it right and
based on like how those two are changing
if the one to your right is increasing
and the one to your left is decreasing
that means your Tau hat is
increasing right if if the other way
around your target is so as easy as that
just by monitoring like three samples
out of the correlator you can it can
almost perfectly track how hot some same
for f and then you feed these back so
the basically so you can generate this
feedback signal uh the one for Doppler
goes to the numerically controlled
oscillator so the output of that kind of
tracks the Doppler Doppler shift uh and
then the the one for tauhat goes to your
local code replica generator so that guy
also tracks changes in town uh and then
almost continuously in time you can
track
sorry I'm a few slides back you can
track basically all your your satellites
any questions
okay
so the last thing which is extremely
important that we need to talk about is
that okay so we kind of have a very good
understanding from the physics all the
way up to the system level of how the
GPS acquires the satellites find their
positions finds these time of flights
plus the timing offset or the pseudo
range to each satellite but we haven't
talked about how do we localize
ourselves with all this information so
that's the the the
uh last piece that we'll talk about and
the idea is
um pretty simple actually once you break
it down so the receiver so far uh what
it does is it acquires a bunch of
satellites and starts tracking them and
over time uh it it needs to estimate its
own position PR using the measured
pseudo ranges
to these satellites and remember that
each pseudo range row I is the speed of
light times the Tau hat so tauhat is
that output that that you're tracking
which is equal to Tau plus your time
delay or your your clock delay which is
uh Tau D so the pseudo range is equal to
the physical range RI
to each satellite plus this error term
which is the speed of light times your
timing delay okay and you have these
rows for as many satellites as you are
tracking let's say big n and it's at
least four right so these are the
measurements that you have
and just to be more concrete what is RI
the ri is the is the distance from the
receiver at point PR to the i s
satellite at at Point p s i uh so it's
the norm of PR minus PSI which is the
position of the receiver and the
satellite which is equal to the square
root of x r minus XSI squared plus y
minus Ys squared plus C minus CS squared
so this is just pure geometry here okay
now you have at least four of these
measurements and what you're trying to
estimate remember is four parameters you
need well your PR which is an X and Y
and a z itself so you have x r y r and z
are three numbers plus Tau D that you
need to estimate you can formulate this
as a non-linear system of equations and
then solve it using your favorite
non-linear solver the easiest one is the
gaussian method that we will talk about
but let's set up the problem first So
based basically
you have this function call it f of it's
a function of the receiver's position
and its time delay or the clock offset
Tau d right and this function
uh it's here I'm highly highly
overloading my notation so be be very uh
conscious about what's a vector and
what's uh what's a scalar from Context
it's there's no ambiguity but mind that
I'm I'm using like a highly highly
overloaded notation here so for instance
PR
I'm just going to do it once and then
the rest I'll let you from Context PR is
a vector in R3 right that's our position
Vector tau is a number
that's just a number so what I mean by
this so so f is a function of PR and and
Tau D so if you stack them together it's
like it takes a a vector in R4 as as an
input and then uh the F itself
F of
PN Tau uh it is a vector in RN
and N is the number of satellites you're
you're tracking right so each entry of f
f sub I uh is basically your pseudo
range to the corresponding satellite
minus RI minus C subtality right so if
you have solved your GPS equations
correctly
these F sub I's should be almost zero
right because we started with the fact
that rho I
should be actually equal to RI plus C
Tau d right so with the correct solution
this row I minus RI minus Theta these
should be almost zero I mean there's
noise on non-idealities that's why it's
not exactly zero and that justifies this
optimization problem so if you are
minimizing the sum squared of all these
terms which in the ideal case should be
all zero okay does the problem set up
make sense
okay so do we agree that we if we
minimize this function over p and Tau we
have not only localized ourselves we
have also found our timing offset with
respect to the GPS system
okay let's solve it so it's a it's a
non-linear function of course right
there's like square roots and other
stuff
but again there's there's many many many
different uh algorithms for solving
non-linear systems we'll use the Gauss
Newton and the the way the gaussian
works just as a reminder is if if our
function was linear so if you had
another
optimization problem which was minimize
some like ax minus B
Norm squared we all know this is a
linear least squares and we all know how
to solve this right like your X hat is
equal to a transpose a inverse
a transpose B the famous equation you
probably have seen like in 108 or some
other course right so linear stuff we
know there's closed form Solutions and
then non-linear the idea of Gauss Newton
is start from some gas for your solution
at each step linearize this function so
approximated by some ax minus B
Find Your linearized solution use that
as your new iterate and then continue
linear so you linearize solve linearize
solve linear solve until you converge so
and by convergence we mean the Your
solution is not changing much and that
that's the point of convergence okay so
uh let's do that again the objective is
minimize uh
minimize this function here
and this is the Gauss Newton you start
from some initial guess of your position
and timing offset really doesn't matter
much especially at the cold start you
might not have a good guess modern
receivers do because there's other ways
of kind of guessing where you are for
instance from Wi-Fi signals these days
you can reasonably well localize
yourself just from the IP address you
can query on the internet where am I or
whatnot and that already gives you like
a decent estimate of your row if not
just start random right just pick a
point on the surface of the Earth and
then usually these problems are well
behaved and you converge to the right
solution but again so so at each step
you
guess
yes you guess is the least squares
solution using the linearized version of
of F and then you update and continue
until convergence and by convergence we
mean the value of your F that you're
trying to minimize at the current
iterate minus its value at the previous
iterate if it's less than some threshold
that you can decide then you you call it
good and you stop okay
all right so uh
let's go one one step deeper and
actually derive what the linearization
looks like for this uh I mean these days
you can just go to Python and just enter
this into I don't know your favorite
again like scikit-learn or whatever
package you use and it will take care of
it but I think it's important to uh not
be scared of doing these kinds of
derivations that's why I like to really
uh from scratch derive uh uh what what
what all the steps are for instance for
the gasoline okay so again the idea is
at a step we linearize our function so
and the linearization is the value is
equal to the value of F at at the
current point plus again don't be scared
by the notation this is just the first
order Taylor expansion this DF which is
the derivative or for the vector case
the Jacobian matrix of F at the current
iterate times the point minus its
current estimate again this is the
notation gets a little scary but this is
nothing
other than in the scalar case if you had
some function f of x you can say my f of
x is almost equal to around the point x0
I'm linearizing so f x 0 plus F Prime x0
times x minus x0
this is exactly that except the notation
is a little uglier because our X is now
this guy so that's X right or x0 and
that's x0
and DF is like the F Prime for the
vector case and this is X and that's my
current iterate x0 right nothing really
beyond that as simple as that but let's
actually find what the what the Jacobian
or the derivative of our f is I mean we
we explicitly know the function from
here right these are the FIS so we can
take the derivative of this guy with
respect to x y z and Tau and explicitly
find the Jacobian and if you do that
it's actually not too bad you take the
derivative so for instance the the the
the first row of T is the partial
derivative f i or the First Column is
the partial derivative of I partial X
and that becomes equal to this guy here
which is the current iterate of x minus
the x of the satellite this is very
important minus x s i so this is
receiver this is for satellite so XR
minus XS over basically PR minus PS
which is the total distance from the a
receiver to the satellite Y and Z look
very similar basically you just because
the function was exactly identical for
XYZ the one that is different and
simpler is Tau once you take the
derivative with respect to Tau you just
get minus C right and again if you go
back here to where our function was this
is clear if you take the derivative of
this guy with respect to Tau this goes
away there's no Tau dependency here it's
just minus C right okay
so now you have this and
that's basically your your linearization
step so now you can approximate your f
as ax minus B that's a linear
approximation and as I said and
explicitly that's what the a is that's
the is the is the uh Jacobian evaluated
at the case iterate and the B is this
term
and this we know how to solve basically
your next iterate is just a transpose a
inverse a transpose B with the A and B
that are coming from the linearization
step so that gives your next iterate and
then you keep continuing until until
conversions and again at the end of this
process of guess Newton you have
localized yourself so you have found
your position vector and you have found
your
time delay
okay so how long does it take after a
cold start usually you don't need that
many steps actually for the gaussian
usually five or so steps is enough to
get to conversions and that's at the
cold start so you'll almost have no idea
where you are after that you can always
initialize your gas Newton with your
previous estimate of Tau and P and then
almost in one step always you just
converge which is extremely fast and
that's why the GPS works so so fast and
reliably even without much much compute
resources
okay
that GPS can do and actually does which
we haven't talked about yet you could
also estimate your velocity in addition
to position which is extremely extremely
useful and why can't we do that because
remember we also have the Doppler
information we are tracking the Doppler
shift at the receiver so what is a
Doppler shift remember the Doppler shift
with respect to the I satellite is
basically given by this expression which
is the inner product of the relative
velocity of the receiver to the
satellite uh to the inner product with
the unit Vector that points from the
receiver to the satellite divided by the
speed of light times FC right so it's
the projection of the relative velocity
into the radial direction from the
receiver to the to the satellite is
scaled by the speed of light or divide
by the speed of light times the carrier
frequency so specifically it's equal to
your receiver velocity minus this the
ice satellite velocity inner product it
with this is our hat which is p receiver
minus P satellite divided by the norm of
P receiver minus P satellite so that's
the unit Vector pointing from the
receiver to the satellite over c times
FC now if you look at this expression
here
everything except VR is known to the
receiver right you have already solved
your GPS equation so you know your own
position PR is known PSI is the
satellite position which is known from
the ephemeris right uh denominator same
thing speed of light is known prps are
known f c that security frequency is
known right the Doppler shift is known
your track you're estimating and
tracking it so the FDI is also known and
the satellite velocity is also known
again because you're very accurately
tracking the the position of the
satellite you can just estimate its
velocity from the consecutive position
measurements so the only thing that is
not known to the receiver is this VR
right so again you you have a a system
of equations that you can solve and find
your velocity it's even easier than
position because this one is linear
right for position we add a non-linear
system of equations hey here you have a
perfect it's just inner products and you
know scale factors basically so you can
form a linear system of equations solve
it and then you also estimate your your
velocity which is again extremely
extremely useful so that's why if you
remember we said there's some limited
podometry that you get from uh from GPS
which is good why is it limited because
remember uh the the the estimate of
Doppler is kind of coarse it's uh it's
it's 250 Hertz bins
um so so that's what makes it a little
limited because FD is coarsely estimated
it's not a very very very accurate
estimate but other than that this works
perfectly and and and and pretty much
every GPS does that any questions about
localization and uh
and basically the velocity estimation or
odometry here
okay almost done with the GPS there's
just a final closing uh remarks I want
to make
um so one is about the area sources of
the GPS GPS is very error prone as all
of us know from experience and the main
sources of error one is the
satellite position broadcaster so the
the the ephemeris messages that come
they're not perfect right so there could
be up to one meter inaccuracy in the
broadcasted position of the satellite
versus the actual position so that's one
the other one is atmospheric delay so
there's different layers in the
atmosphere and the two that are
Troublesome for the GPS are the upper
layer which is the ionosphere and then
one of the lower layers which is the
troposphere and the the the speed of
light changes in these layers and it's
dependent on the angle of incidence so
so that's uh a source of error and it
can add up to 5 meters of localization
error to the GPS the biggest one is
multi-path interference and what
multipath is is that this signal what
you want really is is the signal that is
direct line of sight from the
transmitter to the receiver right and
and that's then the time of flight is
proportional to the range but what can
happen is that you can bounce off other
surfaces so the GPS signal might hit
some other building near you or some
other you know surface and some of these
surfaces at the gigahertz frequencies
they kind of act like mirrors so the
signal bounces off of that and then
reaches you and then the the actual
pseudo range that you find is actually
then the sum of the two pieces of the
multivalence or it can be more than two
actually you can have multi-balance that
is you know reflected three or four
times and that completely messes up your
localization because the underlying
assumption in the GPS localization is
the the time of flight is is in a direct
line of sight that can introduce off to
100 meters
um if you ever use your GPS in downtown
San Francisco it's almost useless I mean
always like get lost because and that's
multi-path because you get hundreds of
meters of of inaccuracy and the final
one is the interferences there's always
like electromagnetic interferences and
natural noise in the environment that
couples into the signals not a big deal
but it can cost up to a meter of of
inaccuracy so all in all you can have up
to 100 meters of inaccuracy in the worst
case maybe a little more but on average
GPS is
reasonably accurate and you get like up
to a meter or so
uh the other one is about time and GPS
so as as we saw a byproduct of solving
the GPS equations is you estimate your
timing offset uh Tau D and then you then
with that you can compensate that and
subtract it from your clock basically
and then every clock and every receiver
is synchronized to the GPS clock and
this is a very accurate synchronization
because even with the with the slowest
code which is the ca it's one
millisecond a thousand bins so one bin
is a microsecond so your timing offset
is compensated to microsecond accuracy
right and then it's the amazing
basically byproduct of the GPS is that
now you can globally synchronize clocks
across the Earth up to microsecond
accuracy and that's that's why our
timings these days are are so accurate
like back in even in like 50s and 40s
time was not this accurate like it was
especially globally the clocks were not
synchronized this this accurately
that's that and then the final remark is
that GPS is only one implementation of
what we call a global navigation
satellite system or gnss there's many
different versions uh China has its own
it's called Baidu European Union has
Galileo Russia has glown us Japan has
its own India has its own so there's
there's other systems that do uh
basically uh navigation and and
localization using Satellite Systems the
underlying principle of operation the
math the physics system architecture uh
all is pretty much exact same and that's
why receivers today
are called gnss receivers the more
advanced ones and they actually acquire
signals from different systems and use
all of them together to do even more
accurate uh localization and that's
pretty much it I think with this we are
done with the GPS chapter and next time
we'll start talking about inertial
sensors questions yes
for the abstract delays why can't the
GPS
great question so the question is for
the atmospheric delays why can't the the
receiver use some model to compensate
and the and the more sophisticated ones
do the way the models work is that the
delays are frequency dependent so if you
acquire signals from two separate
channels say L1 and L2 or L1 and L5 you
can use that extra piece of information
you know your underlying range is
constant but you get different pseudo
ranges because of different amounts of
atmospheric delays and then you mix that
with some models that the receivers have
based on angle of incidence and
thickness of the layers and whatnot and
to some extent they can compensate
there's more Advanced Techniques like
differential GPS which also uses ground
stations which don't have the the
atmospheric delay Factor then and we can
even more accurately compensate for it
so you're absolutely right there's
things you can do to even multi-path
there's techniques you can do to to some
extent compensate for it
okay
all right that's it thank you guys